I told you that 2026 is about to get
weird. Things are about to get crazy.
I've been seeing all these little things
that are leading up to some crazy
prophetic events. I'm not a prophet. I'm
not a date setter, but I believe that
is the year of full disclosure about
aliens. That Trump is going to be the
one to say, "Look, they're here. We
can't hide it any longer. They're among
us." I just believe that honestly.
Tonight, we got a different show. We're
going to talk about CERN. I haven't
really talked much about CERN in all the
years that I've been doing this kind of
truther video type stuff. Never talked
about CERN until now because a lot of
it's just been kind of speculation
hearsay. But now there is a a prominent
scientist speaking out. I'd call her a
whistleblower. Some people might not
think she's that credible, but this is
who she is. Dr. Astrid Stuckleberg.
She's a scientist, an author, public
speaker, and a international health
expert. So, she seems to have the right
credentials. She actually is in the
scientific community. She's been at
these big events with some high
acclaimed scientist and have had some
interesting conversations. We're going
to get right into it and look at the
types of things that she's been told by
some scientists that work at CERN.
>> I said, "So, how many dimensions
officially are living in the CERN?" And
they both said 17 very affirmatively.
And then they started talking about
portal. There's a portal for the LHC.
There's a door open a round door, you
know, like in the Stargate. in front of
the door they have a room and they sit
around the table and and I said, "So
yeah, what happened?" He said, "Well, an
entity came out came from this portal
and and like it sat at the table and
they said this this entity the second
time took a scarf and left a scarf."
What type of scarf in it? They don't
know. They don't they're not into into
the detail. They're they were really
into the event and not the detail and
this entity left again.
>> All right. So what we're seeing, this is
not Alex Jones. This is not, you know,
YouTuber in his basement. This is a
scientist who works with bigname
scientists and has had these meetings
with scientists at CERN. What does she
have to gain from saying these things?
What does she have to gain? Nothing but
ruining her own reputation. Uh, you
know, it'd be easy for someone to say,
"Well, you don't have any proof of what
you're saying." and just ride her off.
And some people are doing that. I I have
no reason to doubt her. And we're just
going to watch another clip. Check this
out.
>> Top scientists at the Large Hydron
Collider, LHC, says that the Titanic
machine may possibly create or discover
on 8th of April for the eclipse
previously unimagined scientific
phenomenon or unknown unknowns. For
instance, an extra dimension. who says
out of this door might come something or
we might send something through it. But
that even with the power of the LHC at
his disposal, he would only be able to
hold it open a very tiny lapse of time,
10 to 26 seconds.
But during that infinitismal amount of
time, we would be able to peer into this
open door either by getting something
out of it or sending something into it.
10 theus 26 seconds, an incomprehensibly
brief moment. But Berluchcci says that's
enough time to peer into the open door
to get something out or send something
in. And then he adds, of course, there
would be no risk to the stability of our
world. Of course,
>> no risk, they promise. And now CERN
wants to expand. They want to build a 91
km ring, almost four times larger than
what they have now.
>> That's crazy. Four times as big as CERN
right now. You know, CERN is at least a
mile in diameter. I don't know if it's
bigger than that, but uh if you guys
haven't checked out Hacked Headlines, go
check her channel out. She actually just
started not too long ago and is blowing
up. So this scientist is saying that
people from CERN are saying that things
are coming through that portal and
leaving things behind or taking things
with them. This other scientist guy that
worked at CERN is saying, you know, he's
telling you how much time you actually
have to peer into the other dimension
that there's 17 dimensions and they're
trying to open up more multiplying
dimensions. That was on the CERN
website. I screenshotted that, threw it
in here. It said multiplying dimensions.
And uh he's But he's rest assured it's
not going to cause any harm to the
world. No, no big deal. Just another
dimension, right? Crazy.
>> As Dr. Stuckleberger dug deeper, she
discovered something that made her
question everything about CERN's true
purpose. The name itself, CERN.
>> The name comes from Cernunos. Cernunos
the the god of uh the um deer and the
deer in Latin is cernunos but it is an
animal beautiful but it's an animal with
horns and that's their cult and during
the inauguration our official
politicians were standing there looking
at the CERN open door with angels and
demons going through it and very crazy
um naked, you know, looking naked dance
with horns on their heads. This
newspaper had um on the second page the
Lord of the Ring, a ring of the Lord of
the Ring of Sauron and it was written
they took the real image of of the ring
and under it was the CERN, you know,
linked to the CERN and the title was and
I have it in front of me in French so I
I'll translate it. Guarantee of
collusion, magic or evil? Question mark.
[laughter]
>> Wow. So, a lot to unpack here. Um,
there's a clip in there where you see
this strange ritual going on. And if you
if you know about that, that was from
2016. It was the opening ceremony. It
was an hour long. Half of it was inside
the tunnel. Half of it was outside the
tunnel. Weird as all get out. completely
occultic pagan right in your face. I
mean, wearing goat heads. They start out
uh dressed in workers outfits, but then
they just strip down to their underwear
and it looks like a big orgy is going
on. And by the end of that thing, the
goat is imitating, impregnating women
that are out there. And all the while,
there's a LED screen in the background
showing a portal and eyeballs and all
kinds of stuff. skeptics will say, and
I'm a skeptic. If I know you guys might
not think that, you might think I just
believe every conspiracy theory that
comes out there. No, I have to have
substantial evidence before I will
present something like this, which is
why it kind of takes me some time to put
these presentations together because I'm
not just going to throw out a bunch of
my own ideas and concepts. But that
ritual that you saw was actually from
another thing in Switzerland. It's just
a It's like the longest railway tunnel,
but it's right near CERN. And I'm going
to show you a clip from CERN that looks
just like the same ritual. Like I think
the same people are involved. Um birds
of a feather flock together. They they
look the same. They're they got the same
agenda. They're doing the same rituals.
And so CERN is not innocent. I'm going
to show you a movie trailer that they
put out where they're doing the same
thing, dancing around in their
underwear, all this ritualistic stuff.
But I just wanted to clarify that that
footage wasn't necessarily a CERN
ritual, but it was some other
underground longest underground railway
tunnel in Switzerland near CERN.
>> They have a rule uh in their uh secret
um societies and stuff uh that they have
to tell us the truth. They have to tell
us if we do don't not say no I don't
consent to your ring um then the door is
open for them to do what they want.
There is like um it's like a pact that
they impose on us without our consent or
no consent is consent for them. Somebody
said 60% people will disappear like that
when the frequency would change.
>> Whoa. What was that? 60% of people
disappear when the frequency changes.
Um, we're going to look at something
that that reminded me of. But what she
was saying here, first of all, let's go
back to where she said the name CERN
came from this god. I don't even
remember the name of it, but it was a
god of the deer with antlers and
everything. And that's why she was tying
it to that ritual of the railway, the
underground railway system because they
were wearing these goat heads and animal
heads and carrying horns and antlers um
as well. But what happened at that
ritualistic ceremony was there was a
bunch of elites in suits watching this
disgusting display and and what was on
screen looked very much like a Stargate.
You have this it was always a circle
with a portal going on and it looked
like things from Doctor Strange or
something like these kaleidoscopic
eyeballs and arms and just weird stuff.
What' she say right before that? She
said something right before I got thrown
off by 60% of people being gone.
>> Uh that they have to tell us the truth.
>> Oh yeah. Revelation of the method,
predictive programming. So a a cultist,
this is what they believe. They believe
in in karma and things like that. And
and so if they're going to do a ritual,
they have to show it to you in some form
or fashion. whether it's a TV show, a
movie, a game, or whatever, they're
going to show it to you probably
multiple times, because when you
willfully watch these things, and I talk
about this all the time when I give
presentations on media, you know, as
Christians, we think, "Oh, I can just
watch whatever I want because it's not
real. I don't drink. I don't smoke. I
don't cuss. I don't fornicate. I'm a
Christian." And we're watching the filth
of the world, whether it's Deadpool or
Twilight or Harry Potter or whatever.
It's glamorizing the occult, witchcraft,
adultery, all these things, and we think
that's okay. When really, we are
entertaining our minds with wickedness.
The Bible says in Romans 1:32 that not
only those that do such things are
worthy of death, but those who take
pleasure in those that do them. So, if
you are watching something, you can you
might say, "I'd never be a witch. I'd
never kill anybody." But if you're
watching it and being entertained by
literally what God calls an abomination,
you are just as guilty because you're
taking pleasure in it. You're watching
it and loving it. And when you take
pleasure in wickedness, what does that
do? Opens up the door for Satan to have
right, legal right, legal access into
your life. The demons are legalistic.
They play by rules. They have to because
they can only do what God allows them to
do. But when Satan sees an open door, he
says, "Look, I don't I don't care if
that's your child. Look what they got on
the wall. Look what they're watching
right now. Look what they're listening
to. I'm going in. They're giving me
legal right. If you don't believe that,
then you're being willfully ignorant.
This is a real thing. And we need to
wake up. We need to stop playing around
and taking the Lord's name in vain." You
know what that means? It's not just
saying his name as a cuss word. Taking
the taking God's name in vain is to call
yourself a Christian but not have any
fruit. You're giving God a bad name by
saying, "Yes, I'm a follower of Christ
and I can do all these things of the
world. I can drink. I can smoke. I can
fornicate. I can watch all the filth of
the world." That is taking the Lord's
name in vain and it's opening up the
door for demonic access into your life.
Take that warning seriously. She said
60% of the population would disappear
with this frequency. It made me think of
this website called Deagle. De Age G-
Lel. It's like this military website
that looks at all these statistics and
it predicts things. And I remember this
came out like 5 years before 2025. So 6
years ago, this was predicting that in
2025, the world's or the United States
population would go from 327 million to
100 million. Why? Why was that? Like
that is a headscratcher. Nobody has the
answers. It's just this mystery that
this government website that predicts
these statistics is was predicting that
in 2025
there'd be a third of the population
more than a third of the population
gone. Why? What's going is that
predictive programming for the next
pandemic or 5G or who knows what CERN? I
don't know. But I've never seen more
people in my life die as I have in the
past four years. I lost a daughter. I
lost my mother. Uh a friend I worked
with right now is on hospice. He's he's
maybe maybe 50 years old and and it's
just a matter of time before he's gone.
I I can't understand what's going on.
What is the link? Because it's it's not
the same thing. My my daughter my mom
never got the jab. Um it's just
different things that are going on, but
something is going on in our world. We
are like the science experiment right
now. We don't know what happens to years
of use of microwaves and cell phones and
uh Gwen towers and HARP and CERN and all
this stuff is brand new. We have no idea
what this is actually doing to people.
So, I I looked into CERN and I asked,
"Is CERN actually on the site of
Apollo's temple?" Because I I had heard
that before and I looked it up and you
know, you can always trust Google. You
don't even got to fact check it because
it's always true. Nonbias, right? No,
it's not true that CERN sits directly at
top an ancient temple of Apolon or
Apollo in Geneva. This claim is a
baseless conspiracy theory. So glad to
know it's a baseless conspiracy theory.
CERN, located near Geneva, is a modern
scientific research facility with no
direct connection to any ancient
religious site of Apollo. All right? So
there's no connection to any any
religion with its underground facilities
built to study uh particle physics.
That's the whole purpose, guys. It's
just science. That's it. Um, location
misconceptions. While CERN's large
hydron collider lies in a 27 kmter
tunnel beneath the French Swiss border,
it is not built upon ancient known ruins
of Apollo's temple. Now, check this out.
It's going to give you some history,
historical accuracy. The famous temple
of Apollo was located in Deli, Greece,
not near Geneva, Switzerland. They're
not denying that there is a location
where Apollo's temple was, but it's in
Deli Greece. Remember that deli Greece.
Now it says purpose CERN is dedicated to
scientific exploration and understanding
the fundamental laws of nature not a
cultism or or mythology. No, not at all.
So they're telling you this biased
information saying look this is all
science nothing absolutely nothing to do
with religion or the occult or mythology
and anything any anything that somebody
said that was like that is a baseless
conspiracy theory. The myth likely stems
from from internet-driven
sensationalized conspiracy theories
attempting to link modern science with
ancient religious figures often playing
on Apolon the destroyer referenced in
Revelation 911. All right, that's what
they're saying right now. Let's fact
check. Let's look at some official CERN
websites. All right, Deli. Wait a Deli.
What is that? We just saw where was
Apollo's temple? Deli Greece. Okay. Now,
CERN actually has a name called Deli.
And it says Deli goes home to Deli.
Meaning, it's not just called Deli, but
it goes home to Deli,
home of the Apollo Temple. Now, this was
in December 2001. December 4, 2001.
Check out the rest of this.
Although CERN's leap electron positron
collider finished operating in November
2000, analysis of the enormous amount of
data is produced will continue for some
time. On September 19th through the
25th, the collaboration of the Deli
experiment held a meeting in Deli,
meaning Deli, Greece, on the slopes of
Mount Parnosus
in Greece to discuss recent results.
Why is CERN going to Deli, Greece to
discuss the results? Well, look, we we
see right here that the most famous
temple of Apollo is located at the
archaeological site of Deli in central
Greece, situated on the slopes of Mount
Pernaces, right here. Same thing. The
slope of Mount Pernaces. The slope of
Mount Pernaces. Is Is this like a
stretch? Am I just reaching making
things up? This is insane. Why are they
going to this very specific place, the
slopes of Mount Parna, Parnasses in
Greece, and they named it Deli.
The name Deli is an acronym. Oh, it
doesn't have anything to do with Greece.
It's just an acronym, guys. Actually, I
read some articles that said that. Um,
but the collaboration includes several
groups from Greece when the name was
chosen in 1982.
Wow. 1982. I didn't even know CERN was a
thing in 1982, the year before I was
born. These groups immediately invited
the collaboration to hold a meeting in
Deli. Of course, let's hold a meeting.
When as soon as we formed in 1982 and
chose the name Deli, let's have a
meeting in Deli. It's all just
coincidence. It's all just for fun.
There's no meaning behind it. Come on.
Stop digging. Stop thinking too much.
It's just a coincidence. This took place
in June of 1983.
at the start of Deli construction, the
return the return to Deli
in 2001.
So they formed in 8283
they had a meeting in Deli, Greece and
then they returned to Greece in 2001.
Why in 2001? We're going to get to that.
Notice right here, uh, there's a picture
of the whole crew and it says at the
bottom, "The Deli collaboration returns
to its what?
Spiritual home." Wait a minute. I
thought that this I thought Google just
told me that this was all science and
had absolutely nothing to do with
religious, occult, mythology, none of
that. It's only scientific. But why does
their website say the Deli collaboration
returns to its spiritual home in Deli,
Greece?
Come on, man. This is their words, not
mine. Because it says right here, it's
dedicated to scientific exploration and
understanding the fundamental laws of
nature, not occultism or mythology. No
connection whatsoever. And definitely
not connected to the religious sight of
Apollo.
How dare you even think such a thing?
So, here's another article right here on
CERN's website where it's talking about
Greece's first industrial ex exhibition
at CERN. And I don't really care about
the whole article. I want you to read
what's underlined where it says they
were joined by his imminence. His
imminence, who is that? They were joined
by his imminence, the metropolitan
Damascus
of Switzerland.
Who is that? And why is he at this CERN
meeting? All right, this was in October
14th, uh, 1997. Apparently,
his imminence,
it's this guy right here, by the way.
This guy that's dressed like a pope that
has, um, a staff in his hand. And this
is not a wax figure, by the way. It
looks like it, but it's not. And it says
in his inaugural speech, Professor
Llewellin Smith welcoming the first
Greek industrial exhibition spoke about
Greece's pivotal role in the history of
natural philosophy and science. Okay, so
I was talking about Greece. Greece was
known for its philosophy and science.
The archbishop,
this is religion, guys. Remember, we're
has nothing to do with religion. But
here we go. Archbishop recalled Greece's
uninterrupted contribution to CERN. Wait
a minute. The Archbishop recalled
Greece's uninterrupted contribution to
CERN and underlined the symbiosis
of scientific research and religious
faith.
Religious faith. Why? Why is it talking
about science, scientific research and
religious faith? I thought this had
absolutely nothing to do with religion,
the occult, or mythology. But their own
words contradict those claims.
So, here's this guy. I just wanted to
look into him more. I noticed this staff
that he's holding here in his hand uh
has two serpents or two dragons. Even
the guy in the background is holding the
same staff. And I have seen um a picture
of this guy with Pope Francis holding
this staff. There's a lot of pictures of
him holding this staff. And you can
actually find a website where you buy
religious um art artifacts or religious
paraphernalia. And this is part of it.
And that's where I got this picture of
it right next to this this picture right
here. I got on a religious website where
you can buy apparently uh church
paraphernalia. I guess if you're a part
of this, he's a a Greek Orthodox. I
thought this picture was interesting
because if you know about what this is,
these these black robes, why do you see
them all the time? Why does a priest
wear a black robe? Why does a judge wear
a black robe? You'd be very surprised. I
I wonder if I could find it on on the
controlled
censored internet, but I wonder if um it
would show me the connection.
Judge black robe
um priests of Baal
described Sherman pagan priests
appointed to burn incense to Baal. Sun,
moon, the term
rott attire
as chimar as
kimarum black robed or blacked face.
These idol priests wore specific
vestments sometimes described as sacred
dress or cloak kept in the temple of
Baal. The priests of Baal wore these
black robes.
black robe pagan priest. It's gonna be
really hard to like find it. You guys
are gonna have to do your own research
on that. But um
actually I'm not going to waste a bunch
of time looking for that. Um but that's
where all this stuff comes from. You
know, we don't even question this stuff.
Like why does you go to court, you stand
before a judge, and he's wearing a black
robe? Why? Why not a suit? Why not any
other kind of formal attire? Why is it
always a black robe? It's just
tradition, man. Stop looking at Dude,
this goes all the way back to the Baal
priests. Everything. Nothing new under
the sun. So, I I wanted to look up what
does CERN actually mean? And I was
trying to figure out how do I look up
CERN without it looking up the hydron
collider, but I looked up um the etm
etmology of the word CERN. The verb CERN
has two primary etmological roots in
English usage. It is either a direct
borrowing from the Latin sernneir to
sift, separate, discern or decide. So
when I'm thinking of that that
terminology like to sift or discern or
decide,
it made me think of the Apollo oracles
because at that Apollo's temple, it
mentioned Apollo oracles. And an oracle
is a prophet who gives answers. And so
right here, Apollo's oracles, most
notably the oracle of Deli
were esteemed priestesses in ancient
Greece who acted as intermediaries for
the god Apollo. And it says they
delivered divine prophecies, advice, and
foresight regarding war, politics, and
daily life to leaders and citizens.
But if you really look into this, if you
look into our presidents and things like
that, you'll find out there is there's
open knowledge, open admission that
presidents like Bush and some of those
before him actually hired mediums and
astrologers and things and would get
information from them about the war
coming up and things like that. So
there's nothing new, man. This is all
the same stuff. It goes all the way back
to Apollo and before that. And so when I
saw this where this machine is called
CERN, which means to separate, to sift,
to discern, to decide. And I was like,
wait a minute. Are they saying that CERN
is actually some kind of fortunetelling
machine, like some kind of all knowing
oracle that they can ask for information
and it'll give it to them? Is that what
they're trying to do? And so I looked
up, does does CERN have anything to do
with AI? Because right now, the closest
thing we have to some kind of all-
knowing technology is AI. And believe
me, what we're playing around with chat
GBT is nothing compared to what they
have. When I say they, and quotation
marks, I'm talking about the elites.
They are not giving us the technology
they have. We're like 20 years behind
what they have. And so I looked up is
CERN connected to AI technology. Sure
enough, how CERN and CA are pioneering
the future of edge AI.
So CERN is literally making AI way
advanced. CERN, think about it. CERN, an
AI, an oracle, a prophet, this machine
that can give you insight into the
future. This is what these elitists want
to do. They're trying to open up a
portal to summon some creature that can
tell them the future or where they can
go back in time and or whatever it has.
They're talking about multiple
dimensions here. Things coming out and
taking things and going in and okay,
this is nuts.
So again, remember CERN has absolutely
nothing to do with the occult or
mythology or any of that. They just
happen to have a giant Shiva statue
outside their facility. No big deal.
It's just decoration, guys. It just
looks cool. That's all. Um I wondered
who was Shiva stomping on right here.
And it says in his form as Natara
Nataraa the lord of the dance Shiva is
depicted standing on top of a dwarflike
figure named Apacamara or Apasamara
perushu perusha.
Okay I always have to read these crazy
foreign names. Um this figure symbolizes
ignorance, ego and the and the spiritual
laziness that plagues humanity.
Okay. So just that in itself if if these
are scientist and we don't care about
spirituality, we're just science just
the facts. We're atheists. No, you
literally have a symbol of stomping on
spiritual laziness. And it's also the
god of destruction. Very fitting for
when you're messing around with
underground hydron colliders. You're
smashing particles under miles of pipe
underground. You're going to cause
issues. There's going to be destruction.
There's going to be bad things happen.
All right. So, here is the trailer for
CERN's movie, and I want you to see the
strange dances they do. It actually
links to Shiva's dance of destruction,
but you're going to see the whole
dancing around in your underwear stuff
just like just like the ritual that you
saw for the underground tunnel that they
opened up. Check this out.
It won a bunch of awards apparently. And
right here, he's seeing all these like
look at that. There's some sigils and
stuff going on. He discovers the dance
of the cosmos.
[music]
Science, guys. Nothing but science here.
Nothing but science dancing around. Why?
We got to start asking questions, guys.
What is this?
Oh, I'm out in the desert
like a zombie.
Oh, I have a spiritual awakening. Oh,
time is flying.
all this uh you know black and white
dual dual dualism dancing around in a
circle. Okay, so the guy in white is
dancing around inside a circle and the
person in black can't get in because
that's what these people believe. They
believe that you you draw a protective
circle on the ground, then evil can't
come into you. And they're showing it
right here
in this trailer. Notice she's outside
the circle. And then what do you got
here? This is exactly the same imagery
that you see in the rituals that they
did for that underground tunnel.
The world's largest railway. Underground
railway. All right. Symmetry.
Just science, guys. That's it. Don't
Don't look too deep into it. Then I
looked Atlas. Why name these after false
gods? Why can't they just be called
something like Adam Smasher or
something? Atlas. Who is he? In Greek
mythology, Atlas is a powerful titan
condemned by Zeus to eternally hold up
the celestial spheres, the sky and the
heavens on his shoulders at the western
edge of the earth. A punishment for
leading the Titans against the Olympians
during the Titan um Titan Amaki. He
symbolizes endurance, strength, and is
often incorrectly depicting holding the
earth. Oh, that's interesting. Okay, so
he is a Greek god. Greek again. It's all
going back to Greek, right? All roads
lead to Greek. Greece, I guess. And uh I
just thought this was interesting that
to honor America's 250th birthday
anniversary,
we're going to have the world's tallest
statue of Apollo or of Atlas. I didn't
ask for this. I didn't approve of this,
but it's going to be here. So, America
is already when you got to check out our
our video on Washington DC. When me and
Aubrey went to Washington DC and we
literally went to the Library of
Commerce and took pictures and video of
a giant statue of Neptune out front with
water fountain and names, goldplated
names of Apollo and Zeus and all these
false gods on the ceiling. And yet
people still think this is a Christian
nation. There's oraorises. They
literally selling merchandise from
Manurva. Everything was the sun sun
worship. This country has never been
ever been a Christian nation. It's
always been funed founded on paganism,
but it was always founded on the freedom
of religion. So you can also worship the
God of the Bible as well. You have the
freedom to do that. You can be a
Satanist. You can be a Christian. But it
was not a Christian nation. And we have
the, you know, this statue of Lucifer in
New York City. And now we get the
world's tallest statue of Atlas. Now
there's a connection. I'm going to start
connecting the dots because Atlas is
connected to um the sea and all this
stuff. So, yes, the Greek Titan Atlas
has several strong direct and indirect
connections to water in mythology and
geography. I'm going somewhere with
this. Why water? Atlas is connected to
the Atlantic Ocean, Sea of Atlas, which
is uh the Atlantic Ocean. Atlantis.
Atlantis.
So when I asked was there a connection
between Atlas and Atlantis? It says yes.
A strong often mythol mythologized
connection exists between Atlantis and
the golden age. The golden age that
Trump is telling us we are entering into
the everything is connected. 2025
externalization of the hierarchy, the
golden age, the age of Aquarius,
and the fact that we have this atlas,
hydron collider, Atlantis, all this
stuff. It's crazy how it's all connected
when you look into it. Spiritual golden
age. I'm not going to read all this
stuff. We've covered this stuff a lot,
but it's like, man, I can't believe how
it just keeps building and building and
building, and you see it all coming
together. Like the videos before was the
tip of the iceberg. Now it's like, wait
a minute. They're admitting that this
thing that they're this hydron collider
is actually opening up portals and
things are coming out of it. Talk about
externalization of the hierarchy. Talk
about we're seeing things fly around in
the sky and the military is telling us,
"Yeah, we don't know what they are, but
we communicate with non-human
intelligences."
That's the world we're living in right
now. Wake up, guys. The age of Aquarius
is an upcoming or just beginning
2,150ear
astrological era defined by a shift in
the vernal equinox toward the Aquarius
constellation. So I wanted to see is
there connection to water again the age
of Aquarius. She's the water bearer. So
now I'm going to look back at CERN
again. CERN held a meeting of its deli
experiment. Deli experiment that I don't
like experiments, okay, when they when
they're on a massive scale like that and
we don't know what they're going to do.
Collaboration in Deli, Greece in
September 2001. What do you think of
when you hear September 2001? I want you
guys go back in time. September 2001.
September 11, right? September 11. They
had their meeting
in in the same month, days after
September 11.
If you watch some of our past stuff,
you'll know that September 11 was an
occult ritual that they had to bring
down the two towers and erect the one.
it. That's what the numbers 9 and 11.
It's all a cult numerology and it was
all a ritual for a purpose to burn down
the old order and bring up the new
order, the one world tower. Now, why did
they why did CERN, this scientific
organization that has all these occult
roots that has a massive machine
underground that's smashing particles
together and trying to recreate the Big
Bang. And we don't know what it does.
says it could open up 17 or 18
dimensions.
Why are they having a meeting in Deli,
Greece, where the where Apollo's temple
is
days after 911?
All right, track with me, guys.
September 11, 2001.
This is what happened like right after
911. I don't know if it was a day after
or what, but check this out. This This
isn't just your normal ceremony, okay?
This is ground zero. This is where two
towers were. I don't know what that
single circle on the ground is, but
check this out.
>> I saw that morning. Uh, you know, being
down here now as different as it looks.
I uh I still have those visuals, those
images in my mind, in my head.
>> We're on as a nation deficiency now.
Suicide bombers, uh, you know, it
happens in Israel on a daily basis.
Those are the things we have to be
careful of. Now we have to watch for
now.
>> Do you expect suicide plane struck the
north tower of the World Trade Center
one year ago? Hundreds of people have
gathered here at ground zero to mark the
anniversary in what is expected to be.
We tell you that the anniversary
ceremony will also include [music]
several moments of silence marking the
times that the hijacked jets hit the
place roses [music] on the site for a
flower arrangement that will
>> What does that look like? I'm not going
to tell you. I'm not going to persuade
you. I'm not going to give a biased
opinion. I see something blatantly right
in front of my eyes right now. It looks
like an eyeball. Why would you have why
would you go to ground zero where a
bunch of people died in this tragic
event that I know was not what the
mainstream narrative said. It was a
ritual.
And do another ritual where you're
literally forming the eye of Horus right
on display in front of millions of
people live on national television.
This is crazy, guys. This is not just
some coincidence. This is not, oh,
you're reaching, you're stretching. This
is all occultism right in front of our
faces. Now, here it is. This is This is
the statue. It's called Water's Soul.
Water has a soul. Now, now we're getting
into the elemental witchcraft right
here. Earth, Wind, Fire, Water, and the
Soul and all that stuff. It's a 80 foot
tall permanent public sculpture, and it
was put up in 2021, believe it or not. I
never heard of it till uh about a month
ago. And it says right here that the
symbolism is humanity's connection to
water. Our connection to water. If you
were to pan out, if you could zoom out
right here and see all the way across
the river, you would see ground zero.
You would see the one world tower. And
this woman is doing the sh the the
finger on the lips shush sign. And it's
talking about the humanity's connection
to water. And that's why I showed all
these connections about um Atlantis
or Atlas connects to Atlantis connects
to Aquarius connects to the golden age
connects to uh yeah the age of Aquarius
and the golden age. That's what they
want. Why did Deli why they have this
meeting at Apollo's temple right after
September 11? When you read Revelation
911,
it says they had a king over them, which
is the angel of the bottomless pit. This
is crazy. They had a king.
Whoever this is talking about, the
elites of the world, had a king over
them, who was an angel of the bottomless
pit, whose name in the Hebrew tongue is
Abdon, but in the Greek tongue hath his
name Apolon or Apollo.
Now you have these scientific elitists
who are doing these open in-your-face
ritualistic things with [clears throat]
miles of hydron collider under the
ground saying there's 17 dimensions and
we're going to try to open up another
one and things are coming out of this
thing and leaving stuff and and leaving
and um we communicate with non-human
intelligences. That's what the US
military is telling us right now at the
US congressional hearings. We
communicate with non-human intelligences
and have been since the 30s. How do you
think they're communicating with these
things?
Satan does not have access into our
lives unless we give him consent and
permission, right? He has to have
permission. And what happens when you
have a big ceremony and everybody's
applauding, oh, this is so great, the
Hydron Collider, this is amazing. We're
we're really discovering new things with
science. And we are giving our consent.
We're praising and and loving the ritual
and the fact that we're so smart, right?
And these people are
winding this thing up and saying things
are coming out of it. Could it be? Could
it be that the elite are creating a
portal for Apollon to come out of and
fulfill Revelation 911?
Why are they going to the temple of
Apollo to have these meetings?
And when you look Lord Shiva, why was
there a Shiva statue outside? She he is
the destroyer.
Destroyer of the universe. Why do you
have a statue like that outside? And
when you look at Apolon, his name
literally means the destroyer. So the
same people, these same elitist
that have a statue of Shiva outside and
having meetings at Apollo's temple are
worshiping the same destroyer god. It's
right in our faces. Shiva the destroyer,
Apolon the destroyer. We're having our
meetings at Apollo's temple and we got
Lord Shiva sitting outside as we're
dancing around. scientist dancing around
a ritual dance, a satanic ritual.
So, I wanted to read the context of
Revelation 9:11 because I think there's
some more interesting stuff in here. Um,
I'm just going to read from the
highlighted part down. It says, "And
they had a king over them, which is the
angel of the bottomless pit, whose name
in the Hebrew tongue is Abdon,
but in the Greek tongue, his name is
Apolon.
One woe is passed and behold there come
two more woes hereafter. And the sixth
angel sounded. So this is in reference
to the sixth angel.
And I heard a voice from the four horns
of the golden altar which is before God
saying to the sixth angel which had the
trumpet loose the four angels which are
bound in the great river Euphrates. Now,
we don't have the whole context, but if
you hear about some angels that are
bound in the river Euphrates, do you
think they're good angels or bad angels?
I think they're bad angels. I don't
think God would bound up bind up some
good angels in the river Euphrates.
But notice the context. There's some
kind of pit opening up and Apollon's
coming out of it. their God, the angel
God, [snorts]
there's
a sixth angel who's sounding a trumpet
and loosing
four angels. Now, when you read
Revelation 16, we also see the sixth
angel who pours out his vial upon the
great river Euphrates again, and the
water thereof was dried up. So, is an
angel going to pour a vial on the the
Euphrates River to dry it up to release
these bound angels?
I'm just asking questions, speculating
here, trying to figure this out because
right now, yes, the Euphrates River is
at risk of drying up due to a
combination of climate change, of
course, reduced rainfall, increased
evaporation, and dam construction. Water
levels are at historic lows with some
projections suggesting the river could
dry out by 2040 if current trends
continue. And this this is what it looks
like right now.
I'm not sure the dates here, but it used
to look pretty full and now it looks
like this omega symbol that's drying up
on the right. And here in 2021 and in
2022, this is one year, guys. In one
year from 2021 to 2022, it dropped that
much.
Are the four angels that are in the
river Euphrates about to be released?
I don't know. I know I'll probably get,
you know, hammered in the comment
section like, "Oh, you don't understand
prophecy. We're not there yet." And all
that stuff. I don't know. I'm just
looking at prophetic events and I'm
looking at things that are happening in
the world. I'm looking at a group of
scientists
who have meetings at Apollo's temple and
they're saying, "Hey, we we got 17
dimensions. We're trying to open up
another one. Things are flying out of
this and sitting in a table and taking a
scarf and we're communicating with
non-human intelligences. Are they
speaking to Apolon?
Are they speaking to Apolon, the demon,
the angel of the bottomless pit? Is the
river Euphrates drying up? It absolutely
is. Are four angels going to be unbound
from there? I don't know. But I'm seeing
prophecy happen right before our very
eyes. I do not believe we have long,
guys. 2026 is about to be the age of
disclosure. They're even making movies
about it. disclosure day and all this
stuff, making documentaries, showing all
the military people saying, "Yeah, I I
wouldn't have spoke out except that I
had everyone else with me supporting me,
and we're all going to blow the lid off
this thing. Aliens are real. They're
demons in disguise. They're rounding up
the militaries of the world to fight
against the second coming of Christ."
It's in the book of Revelation. That's
what it says. These unclean spirits like
frogs are going to the militaries of the
world performing miracles and uniting
them to the battle of the great day of
God Almighty. That is soon to come,
guys. We're already seeing it on the
news. And CERN's logo, you tell me what
it is. Again, I don't want to give I
don't want to persuade you. I don't want
to give you a bias opinion. What do you
think this logo looks like? Could you
not pick a better logo? You you already
have people these accusations against
you. Why do you got a Shiva statue? Why
do you have a meetings at Apollo's
temple? Uh why are you saying there's
things coming out of this portal? And
why does your logo look like three
sixes? I mean, this is the cherry on
top. Boop. Like of all the stuff,
how can you deny your eyes right now
that their logo is three sixes?
Guys, I hope this was eye opening to you
because I truly believe that the end is
near. I I'm looking at all the signs of
the times and I'm trying to figure out
what does God want us to do in these
last days? We could flee to the
mountains and grow our own food and all
that stuff's good. I'm not saying it's
bad. But what if you can't? What if
there's nowhere to go? What if you don't
have the funds to do it? What is the
most important thing to do right now? To
get closer to God than ever before. If
you have any unforgiveness in your
heart, squash that thing. Get rid of it.
You're never going to take unforgiveness
to heaven with you. Anything that cannot
be in God's kingdom, I don't want it in
my house anymore. I don't want any bad
movies. I don't want violent video
games. I don't want secular music. I
don't want occult books or pictures or
anything. I don't want to wear symbols
that are demonic and give Satan any
access into my life. I want to be as
close to Jesus as than ever before.
The end is near, guys. And I know that
sounds crazy. It does. It sounds insane,
but it also sounds crazy that the
military is on the news saying, "Yeah,
we talk to interdimensional beings." And
a scientist is putting her reputation on
the line and saying the people at CERN
are telling me that things are coming
out of this portal
and what is about to happen in this
world. I believe that Trump is about to
say, I don't know when, but I believe
this year that aliens are here, guys,
and it's okay. You can trust them.
They've been living among us for
thousands of years. They've never harmed
us. Just trust them and don't be a
hater. Don't you know just show them
love and they're going to do lying signs
and wonders. And the Bible says that
millions of people are going to be
deceived. The dragon is going to deceive
the entire world by means of those
miracles. That in the latter times that
many will depart from the faith. Meaning
that they were Christian but they
departed from the faith. Why? Giving
heed to seducing spirits and doctrines
of demons. Seducing spirits. Devils.
These demons do not come out looking
like monsters trying to scare you.
They're seductive. They're like the
snake in the garden saying, "Did God not
say you could eat of every tree? Eat
this fruit. Your eyes will be open.
You'll be like God."
He's an angel of light. He's a deceiver.
And he's coming to do lying signs and
wonders and miracles and bring fire down
from heaven. And people are going to
have to rethink everything they've ever
believed. And if you're not founded on
understanding what prophecy is,
understanding how um the Antichrist will
come first before Jesus comes, you're
going to be deceived. Hands down, you're
going to be lost. We have to get in
God's word every single day. We have to
be praying and putting on the full armor
of God. We got to be asking for
supernatural protection, a wall of fire
around our homes, for God to send
leagues of angels to come in and fight
our battles for us. Because we are
defenseless against a powerful foe like
Satan and all his demons. We are nothing
without the sword of the spirit, the
word of God, and prayer. Prayer and
fasting and reading his word and singing
songs of praise to him. That's the only
way we're going to overcome. I hope this
was eye opening to you. If it was,
please share it with your family and
friends. Please give it a thumbs up. It
really helps the algorithm get this out
to other people. If you're new to this
channel, click subscribe so you won't
miss another video. We try to put stuff
out like this at least once a week. If
you want to support this ministry, we do
need your support, guys. We are 100%
donationbased and I know it's the end of
the year, so January is slow. We also do
speak at events, churches, schools. We
went a lot of places this past year and
we were exhausted, but it was amazing.
It was fun and it was worth it. If you
want to give to this ministry, go to
cantruth.org. You can give through Cash
App, Vinmo, Zel, PayPal. We even have
Patreon. And if you like cool t-shirts,
you can buy some of our merch and we get
about $5 per item, whether it's a shirt
or a mug or a a hoodie or whatever. And
if you guys are giving, we thank you so
much. We cannot do this without you. We
see you. We love you. We try to send a
message back to everyone that gives us
something. And we just we want to say
thank you. We can't do this without you.
We love you. We'll see you next time on
Can of Truth.